esports is full of powerful sniper
rifles that define games the op the
operator the intervention and of course
the craver the craver is apex legends
all-powerful sniper rifle one bullet is
enough to down any opponent as long as
you have the skills to hit your shots
but before we count down the sickest
craper plays of all time i just want to
remind you to subscribe to the channel
hit the sub button turn on notifications
because every sub really does count
alright that's out of the way let's get
into it here are the top 10 crater shots
of all time
kicking off this list is imperial howe
who brings the crater to new heights
literally
trapped between enemies with nowhere to
go hal took the only escape he could he
jumped down and fired up at his enemies
giving chase
yeah the house never switching back to
controller after that
coming in at number nine is fury who
showcases some long distance shots in
this clip you ain't rambling
over there only wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait they
bubbled on high all right during the
apex legends global series championship
fury and his team were trying to hold
the zone edge in hill valley his team my
little phony were able to spot a squad
trying to hide on a tower at long
distance unfortunately for them fury had
them in his sights
i collected them
they're so low up there caressing the
wrestling i think i'm knocked we're not
going up there again
taking the number eight spot on our list
is a salty play from mandy i shot him in
the head with a crater how did he not
die look it's happened to all of us when
the hit rack doesn't go your way it can
be a little tilting oh my god
but after a few shots didn't go his way
mandy charged in with the kreber to
finish the job and talk a little trash
while doing it
[Music]
you cheater dumbass
boy nobody likes you
mom's a whale
you and your whole [ __ ] teams don't
get any boosted dumbass dude stop
playing the game please
coming in at number seven is mr evil
monkey who shows us just how aggro you
can get with a craber
i did it again i did it again three
headshots man i did it again usually
when you think of sniper rifles you
think of slowly picking the enemy team
apart one by one
but monkey got up close and personal to
secure a sweet triple kill and win the
match
i did it again i did it again three
headshots man i did it again i did it
again
at number six is a bit of a more classic
sniper play
cooler
usually the flashiest sniper rifle plays
are the up close and personal ones like
in our last entry but here's a play from
otter featuring the crater as it was
designed to be used picking off losers
from a distance
get one nice get dead
here here sorry starts over here
[Music]
coming in at the halfway point on our
list is a series of quick no scopes from
mr arthur
popping off a jump pad with a crater in
hand is the definition of aggro i'll hit
this
you're putting yourself in a horrible
situation open the fire on all sides but
mr arthur went for it anyway and slid
into the kill leader position with style
[ __ ]
jesus christ
[Music]
at the number four spot is a play from
its timmy that only has one appropriate
response
while being hunted down from all sides
by an opposing squad it's timmy when
absolutely mental with the crater
dodging shots hitting those scopes and
absolutely wrecking his enemies
isu is showing up in style for a number
three spot with this ridiculous 360
noscope
that's right it's not just a meme the
fabled 360 no scope can be hit in a real
match at least it can be hit if you're
as much of an fps god as asu
[Music]
need to be
do all right
coming in at the runner-up spot is a
play that looks like it came straight
out of an action movie
[Music]
anyone who has ever played apex before
knows that this game is all about
movement
and honestly nothing is cooler than
sliding into position for a clean kill
playing on his stream shiv did exactly
that sliding into a 1v3 to clutch out
the game
imperial hal kicked off this list and
he's capping it off too at the number
one spot it's how absolutely
annihilating an enemy squad
imperial hal doesn't have an off button
he's all gas all the time and this play
is a perfect example of his aggressive
style his enemies tried to escape
through a wraith portal but when it
comes to how
nowhere is safe
[Music]
oh my god oh my god
all right folks that is our list did we
miss any incredible crater shots that
you think we had to put on here well you
know what to do let us know in the
comments thanks so much for watching and
we'll see you all in the next one
[Music]
you
you're absolutely molding brother i'm
sorry that had to happen to you
what the [ __ ] is he doing oh he got it
he's right armor
is
on the ramps to be like 80.